قاعده لتروسيا عن وقف الاطلاق النار في
اوكرانيا بمناسبه عيد الميلاد وفق المذهب
الارثوذكسي لمده 36 ساعه اعتبارا من
الساعه الثانيه عشر يوم السادس من يناير
كانون الثاني وذلك تلبيه لدعوه رئيس
الكنيسه الارثوذكسيه وصف مستشار رئاسه
الاوكرانيه دعوه البطريرك الى الهدنه
بانها فخ ساخر وعنصر دعايا في ساق متصل
اعلنت السلطات الاوكرانيه رفضها لاي اتفاق
سلام مع موسكو من شانه ان يسمح على روسيا
بالالقاء على الاراضي التي تحتلها وهو
يطلب ما يطالب به بروتين كشرتين لاي حوار
مع كافه
في موسكو مازن عباس مازن هل من تفاصيل او
فعل هذا القرار وهل هناك مؤشرات على
التزام به من قبل الاخوات الروسيه
ايقاف اطلاق النار على كل خطوط التماس مع
القوات الاوكرانيه
[موسيقى]
وهذه الخطوه يعني يبدو كما يعتقد البعض
بانها محاوله للتقرب اولا من الراي العام
الروسي الذي بات يشعر بالقلق الشديد وربما
الخوف من استمرار العمليات العسكريه خاصه
انه يتم عمليه ارسال الوحدات التي تم
حشدها خلال التعب الجزئيه والتي تضم عمليا
الجنود حديث الخبره ومن المواطنين همم في
مختلف الاقاليم الروسيه لذلك هذه الخطوه
يعتبر عن بعض هي محاوله راي العام الروسي
وللتقرب منه من جهه ثانيه موسكو يبدو انه
بالفعل هي ستلتزم بهذه الهدنه المؤقته اا
نظرا لانها تريد اولا ارضاء الراي العام
همم تحت عنوان تمكين المواطنين الروس
والاوكران من المشاركه في قداس عيد
الميلاد واا
روسيا في اوكرانيا ما الذي سيطبق هناك وهل
هناك
تطمينات او ضمانات
اوكرانيا هذه الهدنه وتستهدف المواقع
تابعه او مواقع محتله من قبل الروس في
اوكرانيا
يوجد عمليه نداء او ربما من الكريم
السلطات الاوكرانيه بان تقر ايضا بيهدنا
مماثله تتوقف فيها الاعمال العسكريه همم
حتى يتمكن القران من المشاركه في اعياد
الميلاد ولكن لا توجد اي ردود فعل بحيث
سواء خارجيه او الكريمه همم لا توجد اي
ردود فعل من الجانب الاوكراني لذلك هذا
الامر لا يمكن نفعه
يمكن يمكن
وبالتالي ينتهي مصير هذه الهدنه التي
اعلنها الرئيس ولكن في نفس الوقت ان ان
مجرد اعلان هو عمليا خطوه همم قدم روسيا
بها سياساتها نحو التهدئه
والاستئناف والمفاوضات للتواصل الاجتماعي